let me get your eyeball things on hey
guys
happy veda
video every day in august usually it's
vlog
yeah
that looks so gross
oh my gosh i'm so sleepy from the party
last night we i can't keep turning up
like that
no guys we have three shoots today
one two
three back-to-back
there's not four
is it four no but i gotta film some
stuff out here so now
you're like
no you're you're done you're done after
three i woke up and i was like my eyes
aren't opening there look do i look good
you can't
kind of see them just looks like a
reflection is that yours yeah did you
get did you eat i got mine okay good
okay
see you once i i'm all fixed francesca
francesca make me pretty hello
it's matt's birthday today actual
birthday
yeah i teach you this huh what's for the
purpose of me even being here if i can't
talk
i told francesca i'm like okay i'm about
to vlog so don't say anything bad so i
might as well just not even be here
shoot number one underway two more to go
what do we think of the hair i like i
like it is this a new what did you do
different i used a smaller curling iron
yeah you have a screwdriver very cute
little table screwdriver flathead
yes because i had to install a capture i
didn't sell a capture card this guy yes
hi phillips
you won't even know the
trouble that i had with this computer
yesterday me and jenna basically ripped
it apart because i had installed a
capture card but the capture card
or the pci slot that i had to put it in
there was a graphics card was do you
know like i don't understand the way
word i understand was
computer
okay a little screwdriver i'll spare you
the detail graphics card into a it's
just like it's okay
no idea we're done i cannot see anything
it's so
bright
you look great
makes you look real pretty
look into the camera and give me a
little give me a line
so i can do my job
shoot number two underway are you ready
so ready come and get it
what's
this time it's a photo shoot i can't
wait to go back to smashbox studios i
can't wait to show you guys oh they have
to see the car yeah
oh that and oh my god the coffee bar too
oh i love this place i still found my
wallet and the he likes
but you still haven't finally no that's
sweet
can you believe it i don't think you've
done this many like sort of like back to
back just like no
no i've done two in a day
not with me me no
it was like ingrid in the morning and
then you in the afternoon oh true i
remember that that was that teenage
musicians last year we actually shot
here on
friday we did you already did an
interview because it was really fun and
i got a lot tight and it was really good
and it's all i've been thinking about
since fridays coming back here and
getting a lot
honestly i considered today was gonna be
the day that i wasn't gonna drink coffee
i've already had two coffees a year
about
and
not a good day
i just feel so dehydrated all the time
it's maybe a string of water in between
my poppies
thank you thank you all right so we just
finished up our this is our last shoot
of the day francesca i'm going to miss
you oh my gosh
i don't even know i'm definitely i'll
see you this week yeah the studio is
awesome
but i was telling you guys about the
lights so these are all
hue lights i actually have a review
video that i haven't posted yet but
check them out these are all
controlled
by this
i hope they work okay lights one
so that's probably there well they only
have two options
did it change you know it did so they're
over there so watch
tungsten
to daylight
one's different huh yeah
that's amazing
maybe this one will have it
yeah
no they don't have it either so the
other studio had something where they
would make each and every light of
different colors it was this really cool
rainbow awesomeness
such a dream light
dream setup right here guys
hi
so i came home from the shoot and took a
nap but it's now like 8 30 so i think i
took a nap for like four hours so i'm
pretty sure my body was like okay
you need to go to sleep so i did but it
was a great nap today was fun exhausting
i'll see you guys tomorrow for
veda day
three four
i don't know hope you guys enjoyed the
video actually i have a cooking video
coming out tomorrow i make salmon so
prepare yourself whoa that got really
bright i'm using this flip up screen
because it's dark in here see you guys
tomorrow love you
just get off don't oh